- We must, we must
start pushing on intent.
We should fix our intent, not
our ability to check the box.
(upbeat music)
- You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
I'm about to talk to you about why
I believe kindness and empathy
and every other great
emotional intelligence skill
is the foundation to actually build
a great business, financially, money.
And yet, I'm the child of a father
who grew up in the Soviet Union.
I was born there as well,
came here when I was three.
And when my dad eventually
achieved his American dream
and owned a liquor
store, when I was dragged
into that liquor store as a 14-year old,
my dad sat me down,
and this is the singular
first piece of advice
that I heard in the real business world.
'Cause I was crushing it
in lemonade stands and baseball cards.
(audience laughs)
But this was the first
thing I had ever heard.
My dad and I are driving
to the liquor store.
My dad is really in a lot
of ways the reverse of me,
which means he doesn't talk a whole lot.
But he looked at me, and before
we walked into the store,
he looked me dead in the face.
And my dad's one of these
guys with like eyebrows
that are naturally in the mean position.
(audience laughs)
Doesn't speak, and is
from the Soviet Union,
and looks me dead in the face
and says to me, "The
employees are our enemies."
(audience laughs)
He said, "Son, the only thing you have
"to do today in the store, is
to make sure you watch them,
"so they don't steal."
(audience laughs)
And I used to really hate,
be mad at and worst of all,
judge my father for that.
And I did that because I
lacked empathy and context
and understanding that when
you're first 22 years or
in the Soviet union and
communism owns everything,
the entire world works
with the black market
and everybody steals.
And that's just how the ecosystem works.
But it's so full circle for me
to have the incredible luxury
of being here tonight and an honor
because my natural DNA was
far more like my mother's.
I genuinely believe
that karma is practical.
I wildly believe in optimism
to the point of delusion.
My greatest weaknesses
over the last 20 years
in running businesses has
actually been predicated
in creating entitlement.
Because I care so much
about EQ and optimism
and we can figure it out to
the point where no question
my great regret as a CEO
for the last 20 years
in two different
businesses with the success
that I've had is that
there are people walking
around the world that I
did the wrong thing by
because I love happiness
so much that I was unable
to have the gear of radical
candor that is needed
to offset everything
I'm about to talk about.
However, to this day I would
much rather have a culture
of happy, and safe, and entitled.
Then wildly profitable and dark.
And I believe we're sitting
in a very interesting time.
A time we're in culture in the macro,
we are pulling in opposite directions,
thinking somehow miraculously
one way of doing things
is the right way and yet
to achieve everything
I'm about to talk about,
which is 100% accountability.
Recognizing that us judging employees when
we navigate companies
based on a P&L is ludicrous
and audacious and unkind in a world where
I genuinely believe
that, you know, actually,
let me throw this in here and
this may help frame it up.
When I think about being a
media, my current company,
900 people, global, Singapore,
London, New York, LA,
it's an agency.
Tough game.
Client services is brutal.
It's a real rugged game.
I believe that I've done
a lot of things wrong
and a lot of things right,
but I believe genuinely
that the reason the organization
continues to flourish
is because we look at
it as the honey empire.
Honey over vinegar.
There is no reason not to
be kind and compassionate.
The meta nature of what
transpired today in
my organization without
going into him or her today,
literally today, my organization fired one
of the single most productive
financial employees
in our company for 100% reason of
he is just not a good communicator
or she too, Goddammit.
(audience laughs)
There's just not a good
communicator to people around them.
I do not know how to say this
in any other words than the following;
I believe the technology advancements
over the next half century
will prove out the hypothesis
that I will lay in front of
you, which is the following;
making decisions far more
predicated around people
that have humility.
People that have kindness,
generally likable people drives
bigger financial results,
period.
End of story and let us
collectively look ourselves
in the mirror and understand
that the far majority
of businesses that are
in corporate land are
run by CFOs, not CEOs.
And let us accept that
a CFO that she or he has
to navigate an organization to make
its payroll to hit its numbers.
I think we judge, there
are many people here
in the HR profession.
You know I for a long time
called myself an HR driven CEO.
You can watch videos of me
in 2007 on the internet.
Fat me talking about that
long before this was cool,
long before this was in the consciousness.
But it took me an evolution
to understand the thing
I opened with because I
wanted to get right to it,
which is I wasn't finding
the right balance.
It was a little bit too much optimism.
I had to find the cadence
and now I navigate
and more importantly because
I hate focus groups of one,
I watch and analyze and
look at so many businesses.
I believe that you can have both.
I believe that there is an
unbelievably powerful opportunity
for businesses to have
friction between the CFO
and as we call it at VaynerMedia,
the chief heart officer.
Claude silver holds this
position in my organization.
She is my direct report.
Not only that,
she is the number two person
within our organization.
Weekly, monthly, we sit
and have strategy, people,
business meetings where if her
and the CFO do not see eye to eye,
the tie goes to the rudder to her.
That is wildly unheard
of in our society today
and much like most of the things
that I've had my hand in historically,
it becomes correct.
Is there so much naivete at the
wall street, Silicon Valley,
business alpha DNA to not
understand that retention
and happiness leads to
dramatic more results
than appeasing the best
salesperson even though
they have a tornado and wipe out
everybody internally in their path.
(audience applauds)
I appreciate that sir, 'cause it's right.
In actually--
(audience applauds)
I have come to realize
something remarkable.
Growing up in a family
liquor store business where
your business paid for your life.
So this was not about awards
or weird reports or theory.
This was life and then
going into startup world
where I invested, it was life to come
into corporate land over the last decade.
I am fascinated by the
ability of corporate America
and global corporate organizations
to have somehow systematically
eliminated common sense
from the equation.
(phone rings)
Hey guys, sorry to interrupt your video.
I'm just giving you this
call for my number to let
you know that you have to
join my text community.
(212) 931-5731.
Hit me up with a text.
If common sense had a place
in current big business,
we wouldn't even need to talk about HR.
It's people.
It's always gonna be people.
Nobody's paying more
attention to blockchain
and AI and machine learning
and all that than me
and I promise you, it's going to be people
until the robots come
along and kill all of us.
(audience laughs)
which I think they might.
It's going to be people.
We have to start getting much
smarter around hidden costs.
Letting go of somebody to hit a number
who's kinda something on the numbers,
but is the beat, the heart, the glue and
it makes 12 other people want
to come to an organization.
That person needs to be
rewarded financially, not fired.
(audience applauds)
And before this gets way too foofy foofy!
(audience laughs)
I wanna remind everybody that
I think of my organization
as the honey empire.
I am out here to put
everybody out of business.
I wanna win.
I wanna build the biggest
company in the world.
I wanna buy the New York jets
and win a Superbowl and then die.
(audience laughs)
Not knowing anything about the real world
because I was a terrible student and
I was completely 100% focused
on the end consumer
always lemonade stands,
baseball cards, the wine
business, VaynerMedia.
I didn't even know these
conversations existed.
I don't even understand
what we're debating.
How can you have an organization
when the asset is people
where that is not the thing we
spend the most time and then
I understood, Oh, weird, right?
Because I was a DNF student.
I'm not good at black and
white, but I dominate gray.
I dominate gray, right?
People don't have the
emotional intuitive luck
of the draw.
Some of you, I'm looking around.
Some of you are just born really pretty.
Some of you are fast,
some of you are tall.
Some people just get it
when it comes to people
and if you get it when it comes to people,
you have to start leaning
into things like empathy, compassion.
You have to become much more thoughtful.
All our political stuff right now,
nobody's deploying any empathy to anybody.
Everybody's on tilt.
Everybody's on their point of view.
That's happening in our society.
It's happening definitely
within the four walls
of our organizations and at the tippy top.
This is just one bad game of wall street
and I'm not mad at wall
street even though....
I'm not mad.
(audience laughs)
I'm mad at games that have to be played
in every 90 day terms and
if you don't play within
that 90 days, you become vulnerable.
It's very easy to be the head
of people and make decisions
around people and be mad at
the CEO and be bad at her,
but you're not the one on
a phone call with investors
with on wall street every
90 days explaining why.
Don't worry everybody who's
put their money into us.
A lot of it, good news.
I know that our money looks real bad,
but everyone's super happy.
(audience laughs)
Most CEOs don't have the
luxury of having enough control
to let that play out and really
manifest within a decade.
Most don't even care.
Let me promise you one thing.
If you have some North star of Nirvana,
of businesses that really care
about people and your company
in one way or another,
ladders up to something
that is publicly traded,
please stand up and leave Dallas, now.
I mean that do not be naive and it's,
there's nothing necessarily
massively wrong with that,
but delusional ideology of the game
you're actually playing
always leads to frustration.
It's just the way it is.
You wanna be 100% centric
around the people narrative.
Go become a weird Yoda in a cave and Peru
because if you're in a
business that has a P&L
that has to hit numbers,
the other part's gonna
be part of the equation.
But I argue that it has
gone ridiculously too far,
that in the consolidation
of corporate stuff
and good students that like
numbers and Excel sheets,
we have lost so much of what SMBs
and family businesses have
run on, which is the nuances.
I, out of sheer luck
that my parents had sex
at the right moment, have the DNA that
I pulled very hard from both sides.
I pull very hard from both sides.
I will always choose longterm
people because when I look
at my retention of my employees,
I realize the speed in
which thing navigate
through knowing each
other and most importantly
when you have an organization
that has limited amounts
'cause you can't change everyone's DNA
and cynicism's really cool.
But when you can suffocate
and over time eliminate fear
from your organization,
very good things happen.
If employees didn't spend
all their time trying
to outmaneuver Karen
'cause they're both trying
to kill each other politically,
they might actually
achieve the task at hand.
This level of common sense
and human truth will play out.
I do not know who the six year old girl
in Tennessee right now is
that's going to invent
the system to score this,
but before I die this will become mappable
and we will actually start the process
of swinging the other direction.
This is just the way it's going to be.
If you are in the game
right now and do not realize
that we will continue to go
down a process of looking
at the nuances of employees,
leaders that can balance the yin and yang
of creating a culture, an environment.
And by the way, since
all the leaders are here,
can we just stop checking the boxes
for the sake of checking the boxes?
Are we really going to be a
culture that pats ourselves
on the back for hitting
a diversity number?
Really?
We must, we must start pushing on intent.
We should fix our intent,
not our ability to check the box that--
(audience applauds)
That's how we'll get to
where we all wanna go.
This is not a sync
issue. This is the well,
and we must have these
thoughtful conversations.
We just must.
And so here's some random thoughts
because I wanna bring as much value.
There's a couple other things
I wanted to talk about.
I think the philosophy is set.
We can get into the nuances.
I'm happy to answer any of your comments
on social over the next 57 years,
but a couple things, just random.
I am fascinated by hiring. I am fascinated
by people's ego to think
they're good at hiring.
(audience laughs)
Watching the world for
some reason take pride
in an ability, a framework.
My favorite, I got this
one question that helps
you be good at hiring is laughable
at best and ludicrous at worst.
We must start talking
about hiring and firing
in a compassionate way
to help organizations.
We have so much ego wrapped up in hiring.
So much waste, so much
consensus agreement.
(mumbles) very hard to make a decision
when 47 people have equal say.
(audience applauds)
We must start talking more
about hiring because guess what?
Good news, the college
gig, it's coming to an end.
The racket is almost over
and it's not gonna be
so easy for you to hide behind.
Well, she went to Yale.
We must be more thoughtful,
but more importantly,
we must look for other
things than data points.
In my career hiring, I wanna
be not over the top here.
7,000 people.
I have called 0.0 references.
I have no interest in
calling your PR person.
(audience applauds)
There is no bigger waste of
time of this collective room.
It is calling somebody as a reference
that they told you to call.
(audience laughs)
You know how I know this?
I've given the biggest references
to the worst employees that
have ever worked for me.
(audience laughs)
Because I like them.
I don't want them to be on the street.
I feel bad.
(audience laughs)
literally, taking somebody who's a one
and convincing the other
person that they're a 96.
(audience laughs)
they'll figure it out.
We have so many things to
talk about in this world
that we all kind of live in.
Number one, actually back to, I remember,
I'm glad I got to this.
I forget so many things, ussually.
Improv has its strengths and weaknesses.
This is very meta.
If you follow, how many people here follow
my content just for context?
Thank you.
Okay, that's great, so most don't.
So listen.
(audience laughs)
No, no, I, that's what I
thought is a lot of people here.
This is wild and if you don't
know me, which is why I asked,
you may think it's a plug,
but let me be very much on a record.
LinkedIn, Facebook, YouTube,
the NFL, orange juice.
I have no emotion for anything.
I care about nothing
except the end consumer.
But with that preface,
there's a very remarkable thing going on
for the far majority
of people in this room.
For the last year, I've
been yelling on LinkedIn
and many other platforms that LinkedIn
is a really good place
to put content, right?
As we sit here today, the far
majority of people's issue
for their business, how many people own
their business or the CEO?
Raise your hands.
Okay, not that many.
You should consider it.
It's fun.
I'm just kidding.
(audience laughs)
But for the people that run marketing
or make decisions or influence decisions..
LinkedIn over the last
six months to a year,
and I don't know when
this algorithm changes
and when the supply
and demand of attention
and content changes, which is what happens
to all these platforms.
My favorite place for last four years,
Instagram is going through it right now
for all the biggest content producers,
especially personalities.
The organic decline has just started.
It's about to get nasty.
A lot of influencers are gonna get a job.
(audience laughs)
Anyway, LinkedIn right now is going
through a Facebook 2012 moment.
You right now have a business
or trying to build a profile
or trying to communicate
something to the world,
have no followers on
LinkedIn, produce content
and the organic reach and
consumption is remarkably high.
It will go away.
They always do.
It went away on Myspace and
went away on Facebook...
Goes away everywhere.
It's supply and demand of attention.
So one thing I definitely
wanted to get across before
I got off here, content communication,
not your personal brand.
Take a bit of different way.
Your reputation, it matters.
A lot of you are still
trading on your reputation
'cause you've been doing it a long time.
Reputation is getting
built at scale in LinkedIn
for B2B businesses which
have never really had a home
for content like they do
now and just being obsessed
with over bringing value.
I implore you to dig into this hypothesis,
get educated and remember
when you produce content
you don't have to do video,
you don't have to do audio,
you don't have to do written
word as a matter fact
my highest over Indexing content
on LinkedIn right now is comic strips
that I create from the things
I talk about in the feed.
It's working. Gifs means you know,
unemotional about how we communicate.
We used to draw in caves.
People used to do smoke signals.
I do not mind how people,
unlike the far majority
of this room and world,
I do not judge how one
wants to consume content.
I just react to the truth and
in that truth at this moment,
not next year, not last
year at this exact second.
There's a huge arbitrage of
organic reach within LinkedIn
that I have a funny feeling
will help you get something
that you want, whatever that may be,
and by the way, as humans,
where many of you may have
your side hustle if
you're selling cupcakes
or your fitness program
or hair extensions,
LinkedIn, which is wild.
Watching it become
Facebook in there instead
of just B2B has been phenomenal,
so highly recommend that.
That's another side note.
Let's talk about a couple of other things.
I think that there's
a lot of weird things about this industry.
For example, I am fascinated by the fact
that people are crippled
by anonymous review websites
about your business.
That we have not had the
proper conversation about
how it actually works,
which is most companies induce force,
scare people into leaving
positive reviews on this site
and then pay these platforms
to hide the bad ones.
And I'm confused by the crippled nature
of anonymous reviews.
Anonymous reviews always
dwindle in their importance.
It's human behavior.
The shadows lead to very little good.
And more importantly, I now
recommend for the HR world
to go the other way and seed these sites
with negative reviews,
allowing them to eliminate
candidates from applying
who don't have the emotional intelligence
to understand that anonymous
reviews are stupid.
(audience applauds)
Real life, real life.
Just look at the business
models of these companies
and answers all you need to know.
So that's a random thought, anyway.
(audience laughs)
That girl in Tennessee is
going to figure out something
and what she's gonna do is
figure out the following story.
I can't believe how well
this worked out to me because
that following story
actually, Adam, where are you?
I saw your face.
Hey brother, I'm a little
looking at a former employee
who I ran in today, who I
fired and during that firing,
which was a very, by the way,
a top 15 firing of my career,
that was difficult because not
only is he a tremendous dude,
the timing of his life with
his family expansion made
this firing unbelievably difficult,
coinciding with me now having
to deploy self-awareness,
which is fun to tell other
people to do and realize
that I was not doing a good
enough job with radical candor
or putting people in
a position to succeed.
But as he told me today, which
meant a lot to me, brother,
the most important thing that
happened there was enabling
that individual during
this extremely tough time
with support and more importantly,
a framework to deploy self-awareness.
The reason I loved him so
much is because I loved him.
The job he was doing for him.
Yeah, not that bad, but wasn't the best.
I am the CEO of my company
and don't have a prayer
in getting hired by it.
I do not have the grammar
skills nor the math skills
to ever be an employee of VaynerMedia.
But I can run it.
That level of self-awareness
must be talked about.
Why did I bring up that story?
I have no clue, but I
know how I feel about him.
I have a funny feeling
over the last four years,
five years, he's navigated life.
I and My company has grown
in profile since then.
I get my name gets thrown
around negative, positive,
but here's a human being that gets to walk
around earth know what happened there?
Know what I did after he was
there, when he was there.
And I have a funny
feeling, maybe I'm wrong,
that when my name gets brought
up, Oh, he's a dick, right?
That he might say, actually,
let me tell you a story.
I know how real life works.
I know that the truth is undefeated
and I know that there's a lot
of hidden financial variables
of the humanity that my business runs on,
not on its profitability.
I know that many of those
conversations have led
to other conversations that
led to other conversations
that became the single variable
that some other human being
decided to do business
with us or come into our
organization and work for us
and drive our business.
I am fascinated by people's
inability to play chess
around the interest of HR and
continue to play checkers.
How do we not understand that
what the person feels like
on the way out matters
almost if not more than
how they feel while they're there.
And so we, thank you.
(audience applauds)
We need an uncomfortable paradigm shift.
People are gonna clap and Pat themselves
on the back all week here on tactics,
on the current state of what's accepted
or what we aspire to in tactics.
And we will come back in
two or three years or within
our organizations and
we will show pie charts
of how we've done better
yet we will continue to live
and operate within frameworks
where the financial health
of the business is 100%
the decision making tree
of the organization.
And until we change that and
until we change the structure
and until we give the ladies
and men on wall street the
ability to build buildings,
and this is longterm.
Until we understand that all
these venture backed companies have
so much inbound dollars that
they're burning their cash.
And if they don't raise more capital,
they'll go out of business
and all they're really trying
to do is go public or sell their company.
So how could they actually care about you?
Until we have a dramatically
more thoughtful conversation
of the intent, until we put companies
that are trying to build
in perpetuity at the top,
not the one that flipped this
week, we will never achieve.
We will never achieve
the level of humanity
that we are looking for all subconsciously
within the four walls
of this organization.
And when will we challenge
hiring or my favorite reviews.
That's a fucking doozy.
(audience laughs)
And I know it because I
promised them I wouldn't curse,
but I had to go there on this one.
(audience laughs)
Reviews, you mean people
that have political invested interest,
making judgment on the people
below them to subconsciously
or worse consciously.
Make sure that they don't take their spot.
You mean that one?
That's right.
(audience applauds)
Can we just get thoughtful?
Can we just get thoughtful and
not that I have every answer.
I spent so much time trying
to be Gary Vaynerchuk,
the human being to offset
Gary Vaynerchuk, the CEO.
When I look at reviews in this,
I spend ungodly hours following all
my employees on social media.
Not to be a creeper.
(audience laughs)
But do you know how many good decisions
I've made in the last
decade by understanding
who's friends with who
in the organization?
So I understand the best that feedback.
Do you know how easy it is
for three employees to gang up
on somebody and create a narrative
that gets that person fired?
Unless you're thoughtful enough to know
what I'm talking about.
I know it's true and you know it's true
and all 5,000 people here know it's true,
and all 1 million people
that watch this video
at some point know it's true.
When, when is our industry willing
to have the actual
conversation instead of digging
in to the surface level
side that they reside in?
That is the day we begin the
process of bringing good stuff
to businesses 'cause they both matter
and they need friction.
But we have to have the real conversation,
not the easy one.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you.